thion georges marchais contre attaque
tous azimuts les cibles ces dissidents
le gouvernement et la presse pourquoi
alain duhamel grève générale en iran le
chat entre la répression et la
libéralisation forcer un reportage
d'edouard leur là messieurs bonsoir une
fois de plus les yeux le coeur et
l'esprit de nombreux français sont à
nouveau tournés vers l'argentine mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas pour ne
penser qu'au sport de bien vilaines
histoire d'argent une influence ont
empoisonné en rond empoisonné par dans
le climat des tricolores depuis leur
défaite face à l'italie
nous allons les évoquer dans quelques
secondes mais auparavant un à côté de
cette coupe du monde nous vous l'avons
souvent dit le mundial sera pour nous
l'occasion de parler beaucoup de
football bien sûr mais pas exclusivement
une grande partie de l'opinion
souhaitent être informés sur ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de l'argentine une
plus grande partie encore veut avoir des
nouvelles des vingt-deux français
disparus ou enlevés là bas eh bien il ya
quelques secondes pierre salviac nous
téléphonait il était professeur d'une
information qui devrait enfin faire
avancer le dossier
on saura demain ce qu'il en est du sort
de 17 de ces français en arrivant à
buenos aires les dirigeants de la
fédération française de football n'avait
pas oublié la démarche digne et
silencieuse des familles des vingt-deux
français disparu le jour de
l'embarquement pour l'argentine il avait
promis d'entreprendre des recherches dès
leur arrivée ils ont tenu parole
avec l'aide de l'ambassadeur de france
et l'appui efficace du brésilien joao
havelange président de la fédération
internationale
deux dirigeants du football français
messieurs saft et sadoul ont obtenu des
nouvelles de 17 des 22 français disparus
en argentine dans 48 heures ils seront
en mesure de donner les noms des
personnes en question pour les cinq
autres dont on est toujours sans
nouvelle
les autorités argentines se serait
contenté de dire qu'elles ne dépendent
pas de leur compétence
l'une d'entre elles est présenté comme
un escroc réfugie en uruguay avec le
coffre de la banque dans laquelle il
travaillait demain midi quelques heures
avant le coup d'envoi du match argentine
france ce qui prend valeur de symbole
les dirigeants français seront reçus à
déjeuner à la maison rose le palais
présidentiel devant lequel défilé choc
jeudi les femmes filles et soeurs de
disparus ils doivent cependant confirmé
la liste des français dont on a
subitement retrouvé la trace de la
bouche même d'un important membre de la
junte qui pourrait être le général
videla en personne c'est une information
quand n 2 et la première vous révéler
elle demande bien sûr être confirmé et
nous devrions être fixés là dessus donc
demain soir
revenons maintenant au sport avec
d'ailleurs ce qu'il a de nobles et de
moins digne je veux parler de la
mauvaise ambiance qui règne dans
l'équipe de france à quelques heures du
match qu'elle doit disputer contre
l'argentine
le match le plus dur de ce premier tour
demain quelques minutes après minuit en
compte d'ailleurs retransmise en direct
par antenne 2 et pour laquelle michel
hidalgo a procédé à de substantielles
modifications dans la sélection
française
quatre au départ quatre joueurs nouveaux
battiston lopez bathenay rocheteau dans
les bus bertrand demanes à l'arrière
michel hidalgo a fait confiance à
battiston en excellente forme à
l'entraînement
battiston remplace janvion lopez sera le
stoppeur de l'équipe de france et
remplace rios marius trésor capitaine de
l'équipe conserve son poste de libéro
vocis arrière gauche reste à sa place
dominique bathenay milieu de terrain
remplace guillou son retour peut
permettre à platini de se sentir plus à
l'aise sur le terrain on sait que
platini avait été fort mécontent de la
non sélection de son camarade contre
l'italie henri michel conserve sa place
de milieu de terrain
rocheteau et vince d'alger à la droite
on doit retrouver avec rocheteau un
véritable ailier de débordement lacombe
auteur du seul but français garde sa
place de même que didier six halal
gauche all avec nous maintenant thierry
roland nous allons retrouver toutes
leurs tirs roland avec bernard père pour
notre émission quotidienne de 20h30 mais
il nous faut d'ores et déjà profiter de
cette liaison avec buenos aires pour
faire le point alors d'abord première
question thierry roland cette équipe de
france est une équipe si fragile au
point de se laisser impressionner par de
sordides histoires d'argent
non je ne pense pas que ce soit une
équipe fragile cette équipe de france
mais il est incontestable que pendant
toute cette fin deux dernières semaines
avant pendant et après le match contre
mardel peu contre l'italie à mar del
plata elle nous a déçus l'argent est
passé avant le football et c'est tout à
fait regrettable ces jeunes gens sont
des professionnels je le conçois mais il
était venu ici pour disputer un match de
football et ne devait pas faire passer
l'argent surtout une somme aussi minimes
on a parlé de 1500 francs ils sont allés
au chantage vous rendez compte pour 1500
francs deux heures avant le match
1500 francs de plus ou sinon ils masquer
leurs chaussures et ça je le répète
c'est tout à fait inadmissible
bon donc on ne peut peut être pas allé
comme certains de nos confrères jusqu'à
dire qu'il s'agit d'une d'une équipe
malade de l'argent mais maintenant une
question sur michel hidalgo est ce que
michel hidalgo est un homme solide
suffisamment non influençable par
certains des joueurs qui parait-il
voulait la sélection de d'autres
d'autres de leurs amis est-ce qu'il vous
paraît suant solide pour tenir en un ces
jeunes gens comme vous dites non michel
hidalgo est un homme je crois honnête et
courageux c'est un homme qui fait partie
de ce groupe depuis deux ans il l'a
conçu de ses propres mains il en est
partie intégrante il n'est pas le chef
il est le grand frère ou si vous voulez
lamy et je crois qu'il a été comme nous
tous comme vous comme moi comme des
millions de téléspectateurs déçu déçu
par le comportement de certains joueurs
je crois qu'il faut les nommer il ya des
meneurs dans cette équipe
inquiet de la génération qui s'en va
jean marc guillou et malheureusement
inquiets de la génération qui monte
dominique bathenay encore une fois ce
sont des professionnels
on le comprend mais michel hidalgo ne
s'est pas laissé influencer je le crois
il a
fait une autre équipe de france pour
affronter l'argentine et c'est une bonne
équipe je crois la meilleure que l'on
puisse mettre sur pied ici à buenos
aires en tout cas avant le coup et ça ça
n'est pas parce que la france a perdu 2
à 1 contre une bonne équipe d'italie
avant le coup meilleure que celle qui a
affronté l'italie
dernière question thierry roland michel
hidalgo démission ou pas non je ne pense
pas qu'il faille parler de démission
michel hidalgo a toujours dit je ne
resterai pas éternellement la tête de
l'équipe de france son contrat se
termine après la coupe du monde à la fin
du mois de juin il le verra les
dirigeants du football français
à son retour en france de toute façon il
ne faut pas parler de démission s'il se
passe quelque chose
michel hidalgo ne renouvellera pas son
contrat mais en aucun cas il ne faut
évoquer le mot démission
ainsi thierry renault s'installe dans la
grève chacun reste sur ses positions et
c'est la justice qui a pour deux fois
trancher aujourd'hui saclay ont d'abord
le tribunal a ordonné l'évacuation sous
48 heures pendant que les ouvriers voté
la poursuite de la grève et de
l'occupation
et puis à flins là le jugement a été
plus nuancé le tribunal n'ordonne pas
l'évacuation lusine mais exige que les
non grévistes et le droit de libre
circulation à l'intérieur cris de joie
et dans ce matin dans l'atelier des
grandes presse de flins
l annonce de la décision du tribunal de
ne pas faire évacuer l'atelier la
centaine d'ouvriers qui continue
l'occupation cette décision a été reçue
comme un premier succès en affirme ici
que la grève avec occupation continuera
jusqu'à la satisfaction des
revendications
mais normal de bloquer toute une usine
comme ça avec un petit groupe a tout à
fait parce que y'a comme ça qu'on peut
arriver à voir revendications ça peut
désormais un gros 4 ans mais moi tous
les mois on pose des revendications ils
sont jamais satisfaites
il est obligé d'en arriver là pour
arriver était compté c'est dans cet
atelier que l'on fabrique les côtés de
caisse de la r18 ils sont pressés sur
ces énormes machines au rythme de 250 à
l'heure ce qui implique quatre
manipulation la minute par ouvrier un
rythme rapide énoncées ici comme
excessifs et les grévistes demandent à
passer ouvriers professionnels afin
précisément d'être plus attaché ce
travail toute leur vie les en bloquant
cette production c'est toute la
fabrication des r18 qui est interrompue
l usine de fin de ce fait a été fermée
trois jours à la direction
oui la direction qui n'a pas voulu faire
connaître sa position à deux jours du
début du rapatriement des troupes
françaises au zaïre la conférence de
paris sur l'afrique a pris un relief
tout particulier
ils sont cinq autour d'une table 5 a
essayé de donner à l'occident une
politique africaine cohérente les
allemands les belges les américains les
anglais les français
étonnement des uns et des autres
américains compris en apprenant que han
young le représentant les usa à l'onu
estimé que le bilan de l'extension
soviéto-américaine en seriez aux
cubaines pardon en afrique n'était pas
significative nos réactions ont été trop
émotionnel at il dit et pourtant quand
on sait lire une perte de l'afrique
on peut se poser des questions dans
cette carte que l'on comprend le mieux
le pourquoi de cette conférence de paris
sur l'afrique
partant de l'angola un beau jour de 1975
les cubains et les soviétiques ont
patiemment grignoter ce continent c'est
donc pour essayer de trouver une riposte
à cette pénétration que s'est ouvert ce
matin la conférence de paris
pour la france il ne peut y avoir de
développement possible de la région sans
sécurité
les propositions françaises seront donc
de de nature économique d'abord avec la
création d'un fonds spécial de promotion
pour l'afrique
financé par l'europe et par les états
unis politique ensuite avec la mise sur
pied d'un état-major de crise qui
réunira tous les participants à cette
conférence avec aussi la création de
cette fameuse forces africaines
d'intervention
les travaux se poursuivent en ce moment
même il pourrait reprendre demain matin
la politique africaine de la france lui
vaut quelques solides critiques dans
l'opposition le socialiste georges sarre
a tout à leur demander le rappel
immédiat des troupes françaises au zaïre
au tchad et les communistes ont organisé
tout à l'heure une menace isation entre
la nation et la bastille cinq mille
personnes selon les organisateurs avec
en tête du cortège georges marchais et
une bonne partie du comité central faut
ajouter à ce dossier les propos du
général mairie reproduit dans la revue
défense nationale de ce mois la france
est assez seul du côté occidental a
proposé l'établissement d'un pacte de
solidarité euro-afrique le responsable
du fln c'est le front de libération
nationale de la corse vient d'être
arrêté à paris à deux jours du voyage de
valéry giscard d'estaing en corse
voilà déjà plusieurs jours que les
enquêtes se multiplient dans l'est
elles ont donc abouti à l'arrestation de
jean paul rudd qui a reconnu avoir
organisé deux attentats par explosifs
contre des gars fait paris et puis
j'apprends à l'instant que 24 personnes
sont en garde à vue à la suite donc de
l'arrestation de monsieur jean paul rudd
alors voyons maintenant qu'elle corse va
rencontrer le chef de l'état le mensuel
qui en est un mensuel corse explique que
l'hymne départ en état de rébellion mais
qu'elle n'est pas non plus cette île de
beauté encombré de clichés trop facile
la sieste les guitares les bandits
d'honneur
tino rossi et napoléon ces sept corps
cela nous avons voulu découvrir avec de
reportage de jean rouger scène et
philippe gassot premier volet ce soir
l'accord de tous les jours celle de la
montagne du tourisme pour un grand
nombre de personnes qui habitent hors de
corse l'île de beauté est synonyme de
vacances
mais ici les vacances c'est surtout une
industrie hôtelière je cherche
maintenant on travaille deux mois mais
faudrait qu'on puisse travailler quatre
aux samoa pour rentabiliser nos
investissements et penser être
concurrencé par les étrangers et les
italiens les espagnols les îles
espagnoles canaris qui travaillent plus
longtemps que voulu longtemps que nous
mieux desservis et les ordres et pour ça
que la transat augmente ses rotations
entre la corse et le continent d'abord
et puis que les gens soient mieux
informés pour les voyages ou les voyages
organisés même en dehors des vacances
estivales
après l'hôtellerie le chef de l'état va
sans doute reprendre la longue liste des
problèmes qui touchent les corses dans
leur vie quotidienne en faisant la
tournée du poissonnier dans la montagne
où demeurent les personnes qui ont la
garde des villages en attendant le
retour des jeunes
nous avons essayé de saisir les
problèmes corse de la vie quotidienne
avant de tourner à gauche après bastia
la route passe devant à leiria et devant
le problème pieds noirs en corse
est ce que le problème existe encore
je pense qu'il existe encore parce que
depuis la halle depuis ce jeu de ce qui
a eu cet incident là je crois qu'il n'y
a pas eu beaucoup de choses de faites
pour les gens pour les corses quand nenê
en corse
ensuite c'est la montagne sans industrie
délaissé par ceux qui n'y ont pas trouvé
de travail ou habités par les corses qui
viennent s'y reposer du leur pour eux la
visite du chef de l'état sait quelque
chose
il savait que le président de la
république va venir en corse même de le
voir je pensais que ça va faire du bien
l'accord si vous avez l'impression qu'on
est heureux encore ce qu'il veut
ceux qui travaillent et ont gagné sa vie
ce travail
mais pour ceux qui le veulent oui
loin des villes on se sent un peu oublié
perdu à 50 ou 60 km d'un grand centre la
vie est moins dur qu'avant mais quand
même alors mesdames qu'est ce que vous
souhaiteriez comme l'amélioration votre
avis ce sont les problèmes essentiels
pour les gens qui vivent dans la
montagne comme oh oui l'eau le téléphone
et les folles tout le monde est habillé
communication de temps en temps nous
sommes toujours consommer en famille
grosz vraiment pas ce que nous avons à
la maison
ce personnage et des villes hier d un
film que voulait et on ne peut jamais
alors que l'on paie les abonnements
l'éducation des enfants plus encore
qu'ailleurs demeure ici préoccupante
j'ai trois enfants qui vont en classe à
corte la grande se présente cette année
au bac et si elle est reçue il faut
qu'elle aille en faculté sur le
continent alors que celle ci avait déjà
la faculté à apporter comme c'est prévu
ça ferait moins de frais pour nous voyez
ça fait ce serait plus pratique que vous
aviez l'impression vous les corses
d'être un petit peu abandonné le bruit
du plastique n'a pas trouvé d'écho par
ici le pays est difficile et il a forgé
des caractères bien tranché on ne se
fâche pas on explique nous voulons pas
être autre chose
moi je suis corse mais je parle français
exprès tous les graffitis qu'aux voyages
bastia 2
il suffit de regarder les murs pour
savoir que tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord
mais chez les corses il y a un point
commun la défense de l'identité corse
qui conduit parfois à la politique et
pour un petit nombre aux attentes
quand un produit est corse on ne manque
pas de le souligner la viande le vin le
football le soleil est bien sûr le
folklore le salve regina s'écoute debout
quand on est corse
à
on n'a pas oublié ici que le futur
président de la république a dit aux
corses
souvenez vous de moi je me souviendrai
de vous les corses ont de la mémoire
ah ah ah
demain deuxième volet de notre reportage
avec jean loup le scène les réalités
politiques de la corse jacques chirac
s'inquiète du dépérissement
industrielles de paris en six ans à la
capitale a perdu près du quart de ses
effectifs industriels et le maire de
paris voudrait stopper cette hémorragie
nous l'entendrons dans notre deuxième
journal de la soirée la contestation au
sein du pc pendant tout le week end
georges marchais à la fête des jeunes
communistes s'est attaché à ouvrir
publiquement le dossier tout en
reprochant d'ailleurs le lendemain aux
journalistes de ne parler que de cela
la pétition qui mettait en cause la
régression idéologique du pc compte
maintenant plus de 12 200 signataires
alors en quoi est ce que c'est une crise
original and gun ou le trophée le
premier problème qui est le plus
important la question de savoir si une
crise plus importantes ou moins
importante que celle de 1956 avec la
hongrie le 20ème congrès ou celle de
1968 avec la tchécoslovaquie et mai 68
il semble que ça c'est quelque chose
d'un peu formel ce qui est important
c'est de savoir ce qui est original
il ya deux choses la première c'est que
c'est la première crise qui se déroule
si j'ose dire à ciel ouvert dire que du
début à la fin on sait à chaque moment
ce que pensent les contestataires et
c'est le second aspect ces
contestataires 11 transgresser les
règles d'organisation du parti
communiste pour cela c'est à dire que
alors qu'avant très souvent on apprenait
l'existence d'une crise au moment où
c'était déjà sa conclusion son épilogue
cette façon-là suivi de bout en bout et
d'autre part le fait que les
contestataires s'en prennent un des
trois piliers du parti communiste ya un
pilier qui était la solidarité avec
l'union soviétique
celle-là on sait que maintenant elle est
partielle il y avait un second pilier
qui était le marxisme il ya eu l'abandon
la dictature du prolétariat et d'autres
choses
là aussi c'était en partie remis en
cause cette fois ci c'est le troisième
pilier les principes d'organisation
intérieure elle a incontestablement les
contestataires en prennent à leur aise
avec les principes d'organisation
intérieur c'est donc ce qu'on appelle le
léninisme si vous voulez qui est remis
en cause la discipline à la hiérarchie
et les formes classiques de la
solidarité
bref la crise à ciel ouvert lors qu'elle
est là l'importance réelle je veux dire
numéri en influence sur le plan
numérique quand georges marchais dit que
les contestataires sont ultra
minoritaires il a raison c'est
absolument évident sont peut-être au
maximum 10% je ne crois pas qu'il soit
10% des genres lockerbie
oui on a six cent trente mille je crois
pas qu'ils allaient y ayant un grand
paul brousse voilà donc qui sont
sûrement moins alors cela étant les
communistes sont bien placés pour savoir
que ce qui est qu'elle confond important
à un moment donné c'est pas simplement
le nombre c'est aussi l'activité les
moyens d'action et les idées nouvelles
et alors de ce point de vue le fait
qu'ils aient beaucoup d'intellectuels
qui ont accès à l'ensemble de
l'information plus que les autres
évidemment donne énormément de poids ces
contestataires
alors sur quoi cela va déboucher je veux
dire aussi bien le statut des
contestataires que là il une haine le
lieu il ya deux aspects en ce qui
concerne les contestataires la première
chose qui est certaine c'est que cette
contestation va continuer elle va
continuer pour des raisons qui sont
d'ailleurs d'abord des raisons de
calendrier
le prochain congrès du parti communiste
qui sera très important ça sera un
congrès bilan aura lieu au début de
l'année prochaine
donc il est évident que c'est un laps de
temps limité il est évident qu'il aura
la préparation que tout le monde suivra
de très près et on sait déjà que jan
alston publiera deux livres à la rentrée
et puis je dirais que l'impact des
concessionnaires fera que ce congrès on
ne le suivra pas exactement comme les
autres congrès caron chacun examinera
comment on choisit le dirigeant comme on
détermine une ligne est-ce que les
contestataires s'exprime ne s'exprime
pas alors l'autre aspect c'est le
dernier c'est que pour la direction du
parti gaulliste faut pas non plus en
faire une sorte de drame shakespearien
georges marchais georges marchais
restera en place la direction restera en
place et je dirais même ça sans vouloir
être paradoxal que d'une certaine façon
cette contestation n'est pas tout à fait
négative pour la direction du pc car
aujourd'hui à cause des formes public et
spectaculaire de la contestation
il commence à y avoir une réaction de la
base majoritaire qui est autour de
georges marchais et qui se posent ancien
de sentimentalité de solidarité affectif
et de ce fait les problèmes politiques
sont un petit peu placé en seconde ou à
l'étranger aujourd'hui grève générale en
iran opération ville morte dans un
certain nombre de métropoles pour
commémorer l'anniversaire du massacre
d'il ya 15 ans massacre essentiellement
religieux en iran là sans doute
l'occasion pour les différents opposants
au régime du chah de manifester
bruyamment leur mécontentement comme ça
se passe depuis près d'un an maintenant
regardons et parfois de manière
sanglante plusieurs centaines de
personnes sont mortes pendant des
manifestations similaires c'est là
et moi allons nous avons tenté un pari
antenne 2 et nous avons dépêché sur
place deux journalistes edwards lors et
pire moscovitch jusqu alors il nous
était très difficile de travailler là
bas
eh bien surprise ils ont pu tourner
relativement facilement et l'ont
découvert que l'empereur iranien essayer
de jouer une nouvelle carte peut être la
dernière
un début de libéralisation à 150 km au
sud de téhéran la capitale religieuse de
l'iran comme la mecque pour 90%
d'iraniens 90% de shit devenue la
principale opposition à la monarchie du
shah
c'est ici à comme compte éclaté il ya un
mois les plus violentes émeutes
simorre circuit infernal qui se
reproduit tous les 40 jours durée légale
du deuil des morts des émeutes
précédente
quarante jours durant lesquels chaque
mode l'art religieux chiites s'emploie à
livrer la bonne parole celle de
l'opposition dans le seul cadre la
police n'a pas en principe la
possibilité d'intervenir
les mosquées où l'on se sert aussi des
bavures de la police les deux morts du
mois dernier de religieux a battu par
une soliste qui ne connaissaient pas les
lieux selon la thèse officielle
les a battus tout de même à l'intérieur
même de la maison de sharjah tu m'as
d'harry le dernier des chefs religieux
n'est pas été exécuté ou exclue
l'étonnement de notre part de sharjah tu
m'as d'harry aussi qui pour la première
fois peut s'exprimer sans que personne
ne vienne nous demander quoi que se soit
exprimée en tout cas la position ambiguë
des religieux chiites
nous sommes contre le chah contre sa
politique
nous ne sommes ni communiste ni marxiste
notre seule lutte et celle du peuple
iranien étrange ambiguïté de
l'opposition religieuse qui est celle de
refuser tout ce que la société
occidentale peut apporter ses excès qui
demande également un retour aux règles
les plus traditionnelles de l'islam à
commencer par le voile pour les femmes
mais qui en même temps exige un progrès
de la société industrielle avec les
mêmes revendications que n'importe quel
syndicat du monde occidental opposition
qui ne cherchent qu'à conserver ses
privilèges répondent les milieux
officiels qui justifie ces bavures par
les aléas du développement économique
l'un des pays les plus riches de cette
région mais où les promesses ont dû être
révisée en baisse en cinq ans l'iran n'a
pas su mettre en place l'encadrement
nécessaire au développement de son
économie
30 % d'inflation l'an dernier une
politique du logement négocier avec
dessous de table et à des prix
inaccessibles aux iraniens
revendication reprise par l'ensemble de
l'opposition clandestine qui aujourd'hui
parlent ouvertement avec à sa tête un
ancien ministre président du comité des
droits de l'homme en iran car ils
sentent jabbi 73 ans plusieurs séjours
en prison
ce matin là dans sa maison au nord de
téhéran sans que personne cette fois non
plus ne nous demande quoi que ce soit on
peut dire qu'il y à une sorte de
libéralisation probablement parce que la
situation mondiale d'une barre et
l'échec des programmes du gouvernement
d'autre part on aboutit au régime actuel
à des impasses à des cultes de sac
c'est pourquoi au pari très libéralisée
en poule les choses par exemple je
prends deuxième exemple le fait que nous
soyons là aujourd'hui à téhéran en train
de faire avec vous une interview oui est
ce qu'on aurait fait ya un an
non il n'attirera vous si oui il y en a
aujourd'hui c'est possible aujourd'hui
comment foyer condamné pêle-mêle par
l'opposition la corruption la police les
prisons et le parti unique le rasta this
ici aussi pourtant au sein du rasta
keith les choses et les hommes bouge les
députés modérés ont fait leur apparition
n'hésitant pas à critiquer le
gouvernement réclamant un dialogue avec
l'opposition
les hommes le plus souvent mis en place
par un premier ministre
encore peu connu à mon égard aujourd'hui
si nous arrivons pas en reste au
concorde une espèce de dialogue qui est
difficile que des deux cartes des deux
côtés et peut-être on a raté notre
chance démocratisation ya pas de doute
que c'est douloureux
c'est difficile les visites de décréter
je suis pas du tout à fait d'accord avec
ce que le gouvernement a fait jusqu'à
maintenant mais nous pensons beaucoup
des gens comme moi nous pensons que
maintenant c'est une chance unique pour
nous de engagé ce processus de
libéralisation accepter ces risques et
accepter ces difficultés cetc babur si
vous voulez
une semaine après les émeutes le retour
du couple royal après un voyage en
europe de l'est
l'aéroport est fermé sauf au détachement
militaire et à quelques journalistes
avant son départ le shah d'iran avait
été formel nous répondrons désormais à
la violence par la force
aujourd'hui deux députés du rasta qui
sont démissionnaires
on annonce le remplacement du directeur
de la police secrète là ça va s
l'avertissement des puissances
étrangères carter en tête où la réalité
des premiers indices d'une politique de
libéralisation souhaitée par certains
dans l'entourage direct du shah d'iran
à commencer par la reine elle-même la
shahbanou
les sports maintenant en attendant de
revenir en argentine
trois accidents mortels sur le circuit
moto de l'île de man en grande bretagne
deux britanniques puis un suisse en
cyclisme maintenant dernière étape du
dauphiné libéré michel pollentier qu'il
a remportée gagne du même coup le
critérium c'est un belge enfin à roland
garros les choses commencent à devenir
très sérieuses aujourd'hui début des
huitièmes de finale avec sur le court
central le match au sommet h vilas le
auparavant la victoire de l'espagnol or
en tête basse américain glyn hsun en
trois sets
voici h vilas h filasse ce sont les
derniers échanges c'est aussi le premier
sommet des internationaux de france le
jeune youville as contre le maître
arthur h hne à côté une agressivité
proche de la violence la rage de vaincre
de l'autre la de l'autre la finesse d'un
jeu qui émerveille les plus blasés le
sens du placement
mais aussi pour h le handicap de l'âge à
35 ans il ne court plus aussi vite
d'autant que villa c'est un spécialiste
de la terre battue et que h préfère
l'herbe de wimbledon
l'argentin a successivement éliminé le
néo zélandais pas round l'américain
marco martins après avoir été bien
proche de la défaite et enfin le jeune
français yannick noah et qu il concédé
un set
de l'avis général villa se faisait
jusqu'ici de la corde raide il ne
s'imposait pas aussi nettement que borg
arthur h a souffert de ces rumeurs pour
prouver qu'il ne craignait personne
vilas a voulu sans doute ne rien laisser
à l'américain et il a gagné le premier
set 6 2 le deuxième 6 2 et le troisième
6 2 h battue roland garros va sans doute
perdre un de ses plus beaux artistes
voilà les deux hommes se serrent la main
h et bâti il va s'en aller à wimbledon
une remise de prix il ya quelques heures
au sénat par le présent power celle du
grand prix catholique de littérature
décerné à maurice schumann pour son
dernier livre angoisse et certitudes
directement la météo maintenant un beau
temps chaud aujourd'hui des vosges aux
halles et aux régions méditerranéennes
avec tes orages en fin de journée belles
éclaircies du cotentin à la bretagne à
la vendée
sur le reste du pays le temps était
nuageux avec des pluies orageuses pour
demain bien la météo prévoit un temps
très nuageux
sauf sur le sud est l'après-midi pluies
et orages sur la moitié est de la france
et éclaircies surmotive ouest
températures en légère baisse
voilà le dernier journal vous sera
présenté en fin de programme vers 23h15
par bernard rapp je vous souhaite pour
ma part une excellente fin de soirée et
je vous retrouverai demain avec un très
grand plaisir
bonsoir